okay let's go you for again i think i
played this guy just a couple of days
ago and um okay let's play the open the
zillion can I'd off let's show what time
should play down let's go for some
positional line at least at the
beginning we'll get sharp soon enough I
think yeah this is the classical set up
with Islam scaling and variation which
we transpose into this was done one of
the main battle grounds in the the early
80s matches between now bharathan Karpov
and it's about the only thing I know
somehow I didn't play King h1 which they
have almost always play okay but I don't
I don't know really the details i were
to need to we need to look this up in
the database a book or something yeah
black wants to prevent whites a five
okay I play this after all
okay this is also a typical maneuver
because on the night needs d7 as some as
a retreat square the bishop was bad on
d7 of course so this is one of the
source position so you played reform
think so now the typical of maneuver is
to swing the Queen over and a rook group
to h3 king a queen to h5 I try to do
that it's the normal way this as this is
played but not of course I never had
this on the board so it's an interesting
a heart is trying for counter play on c2
understandable so what is this can I
should should I cover this rook see one
looks really passive not sure if I want
to play a move like that between h4 I
will play h5 and use this Bishop
of course and then have the automatic
sacrifice on h5 but is really quickly on
c2 maybe I need to spend this tempo
after all I didn't like to it don't see
a direct a deck direct way to to make
progress at least on if you place bit of
f8 now and maybe have queen age four and
then h5 I could capture that's not the
end of the world for black but it's
something okay you might have some
tricks now when you fall or something
not sure don't think this is threat
particularly let's try let's try this on
very crude Bishop sacrifice maneuver
okay let's check quickly I take here
takes Queen takes Bishop g7 and maybe
Bishop d4 friends immediate made on h8
cannot take and on e5 if I play can i
play f5 takes f6 Wow could be made
I think this is one of those cases some
where the bridges are already burned I
maybe can take on maybe you can take on
a phone at some point this looks like
dangerous counterplay you for cause the
Sun the weak spot here but first of all
I think he needs so we need to play a 55
ok but I can actually take on c5 with
the bishop maybe and then f5 this
possible and then f6 here
okay f6 is really a strong threat what
can you do I've 6 himself maybe but can
I just take andrew g one King f8
I look g1 first to have this threat on
f6 it takes on g5 now I play rook g5
threatening king a queen edge eight
again
okay let's think first I take on f6 now
he needs to take with the Queen maybe
this is some this is I think more exact
and then f6
now also just he cannot he cannot time
warning f6 am now queen something Queen
h7 everything winds I guess o Queen a
five okay yeah it was a nice direct tech
not sure if it was out but it was
looking dangerous maybe you take you can
take on your phone now with a night or
something a computer also wants to take
let's check this quickly should be seven
of course d 45 Bishop tags well this is
just great what'swhat's is at the
computer now the computer now gives
night a 24 black with 000 what okay then
this attack was it was great because I
take two no human would ever play this
at Lee at least not not in a blitz game
this is just insane move yeah the idea
if I take if I take it then we should be
forced to check and there's also the
special before also covers h7 so I don't
have a direct threat and of course with
the e4 pawn gone I cannot play f5 after
some some some calculating the computer
actually gives night a 2 with a rather
clear advantage to white and then this
attack
just working 9 a-2 rookie won and
somebody I cannot hear in icc i'm i'm
not able to to make variations and show
moves on the bot I think it's possible
but I don't know how it's done so yeah
interesting maybe I'll look at this a
bit afterwards and do some analysis in a
separate video this is really cool
position okay took with a beep horn and
f5 yeah it's now this is just winning
the comp get scissors plus 5 let's check
if I executed this correctly f6 now the
compounds to take my group g1 yeah it's
equally good okay this is it this is
good thinking if yeah then just taking
Andrew g60 i played this correctly fine
of course you cannot calculate this
stuff in in in blitz but you know maybe
I do a separate video this was really
cool yeah all you don't get games like
this with 1g three or something so fun
game for a change yeah thanks for
watching leave any questions or comments
here and make sure to subscribe if you
want to get informed about about new
videos thanks and see your next game